[Musique]
en août 2022 à Bourges dans le centre
Val de Loire la première promotion de
l'école militaire préparatoire technique
ou empt fait sa rentrée
[Musique]
âgé de 16 à 20 ans des élèves de classe
de première ayant opté pour un
baccalauréat professionnel ou
technologique vont découvrir le monde
militaire objectif formé de jeunes
sous-officiers adaptés aux besoins du
programme scorpion qui vise à renouveler
et moderniser les capacités de combat de
l'armée de terre ainsi qu'aux engins
numériques du ministère des armées
les lycéens sont divisés en quatre
filières et seront formés à
l'installation et la gestion de matériel
informatique et électromécanique ainsi
qu'à la maintenance de véhicules
routiers et aéronautiques répartis en
dortoir par section ses adolescents vont
découvrir la vie en internat et faire un
grand pas dans leur autonomie
à travers ce journal de la défense nous
intègrerons les bancs de la première
génération de l'EMPT nous accompagnerons
les aspirants sous-officiers à la
découverte du savoir-faire et du
savoir-être militaire marche pas vit en
collectivité entraînement sportif et
formation au tir une immersion dans
l'emploi du temps riche de ses futurs
militaires français
[Musique]
Peter élève de jour cette semaine
détient un grand nombre de
responsabilités la première de la
journée consiste à sortir du lycée
camarade
plutôt pour les autres
donc c'est mon rôle le matin de la
section parce que sinon personne
il est 5h45
l'école a été inaugurée par le Président
de la République et depuis le protocole
du matin est lancé tout le monde
s'active donc pour effectuer l'ensemble
des tâches obligatoires avant le début
des cours
chaque semaine un nouvel élève prend le
commandement de la section l'objectif se
résume à responsabiliser ses futurs
sous-officiers
sur le tableau on verra ça
il est 11 ok
ah vas-y tu peux
parler de l'embt par le biais de mes
parents mon père qui m'a orienté sur ses
doigts après je suis allé en CERFA au
cerface Strasbourg pour me renseigner ça
va plus j'ai fait mes tests médicaux par
la suite j'étais apte à m'engagé et pas
de filer en aiguille je suis arrivé ici
j'étais surpris par l'esprit de cohésion
qui s'est direct former les premiers
jours le fait que on soit tous dans le
même bateau on va dire
ici on apprend en métier et c'est ce que
je voulais rechercher général ça me
plaisait pas j'ai l'impression de
d'avancer sur un chemin qui n'avait
jamais de faim et quand je suis que le
MPT ça pouvait donner une force
rémunérée
avec un projet d'avenir sur que c'était
forcément bénéfique et nous dès qu'on
aura notre bac on aura directement un
métier alors que dans la vie civile pas
bien avoir un bac pas forcément avoir un
projet d'avenir
tout le monde qui m'a donné son
téléphone
les élèves n'ont accès à leur téléphone
que deux fois par jour le matin on se
réveillant et le soir en se couchant
c'est une distraction en moins pour ces
aspirants soldats dont l'emploi du temps
est très dense et c'est une première
habitude de prise pour leur vie d'après
les ordinateurs que les adolescents
déballent ne viennent pas de l'usine du
Père Noël les élèves de la filière
système numérique réseau informatique et
système communicants font tôt ce matin
leur premier pas dans un exercice qui
les accompagnera toute leur vie le
montage d'une tour PC
vous avez extension pour une carte mère
une cartographie extérieure le type 7
etc etc d'accord on va forcément trouver
du coup sur le système numérique comme
base le nom de finir d'ailleurs et donc
savoir comment ça a marché un PC
d'utiliser et le réparer on va être
amené à ça dans nos différentes
spécialités que ce soit aussi sur un
aspect pour les radios les transmissions
tout ce qui va être aussi obtenu du coup
les systèmes de visée de visionnage et
autres et donc aussi les PC de par
ailleurs
la partie alimentation
qui va venir là
oui si vous voulez
des techniciens à la préparation
l'installation la maintenance des
systèmes dans le domaine militaire
certains de ces futurs experts
rejoindront les rangs des
cybercombattants d'autres seront
impliqués dans le développement du
programme Scorpion
alors le problème scorpion c'est
l'arrivée de plusieurs systèmes d'armes
des effecteurs de très haut niveau comme
le jaguar véhicule blindé de la
cavalerie blindée le griffon véhicule de
combat d'infanterie qui sont
interconnectés avec des systèmes de
communication et d'information
opérationnelles de très haut niveau et
qui donc peuvent conjuguer leurs effets
en partageant notamment la formation et
les effets de leur système down
nous avons aujourd'hui de compagnie une
compagnie de classe de Première une
compagnie de classe de terminale donc
136 élèves en classe de première et 72
élèves en classe de terminale les élèves
sont sélectionnés lors d'une commission
sélection qui a lieu annuellement à la
moitié du mois de juin que préside le
chef d'établissement avec le proviseur
et un ensemble de cadres de la direction
des ressources humaines de l'armée de
terre donc cette sélection elle se fait
sur dossier on veut des élèves âgés de
16 à 20 ans d'un niveau de seconde
générale technologique ou professionnels
qui ont l'autorisation de passer en
classe de première
mois les critères bien évidemment comme
dans toutes les unités de l'armée de
terre il y a des critères de sélection
psychologique des aptitudes médicales
évidemment après il y a des critères de
niveau académique aussi mais surtout ce
qui nous intéresse c'est la motivation
des élèves ce que l'on souhaite c'est
attirer des jeunes talents les
consolider dans leur vocation technique
avant de les AG au sens militaire du
terrain
de
[Musique]
mon projet pédagogique s'articule autour
de trois grands objectifs autour de nos
élèves qui sont l'édificateur de
l'individu former des jeunes qui soient
épanouis bien dans leur peau et ouverts
sur le monde donc ça c'est un compagnon
quotidien pendant unitaire nous formons
également des soldats qui est à la fin
lorsque leur été auront un niveau de
chef d'équipe donc il maîtriseront tous
les fondamentaux du combat et qui seront
aguerris et enfin nous proposons une
formation technique de très haut niveau
puisque nous avons des moyens uniques en
France et par ailleurs nos élèves sont
envoyés en stage au sein des régiments
pour parfaire leur métier dès la
première année de formation
on va s'attaquer au circuit de
refroidissement d'accord donc vous allez
vous placer sur la vente sur l'avant du
véhicule et effectuer différentes
vidanges pour cela il va falloir
récupérer les bacs bleus qu'on a utilisé
dans la salle moteur donc vous récupérez
quatre bacs bleues vous les placez à
l'avant des véhicules
[Musique]
le ministère des armées continue sa
transition numérique alors la formation
c'était elle aussi adaptée aux
équipements modernes la force de l'école
réside dans sa capacité à faire
travailler ses élèves en groupe
restreint sur du matériel de grande
qualité
les étudiants ont maintenant ce vécu les
transports routiers apprennent dans des
conditions réelles en atelier les
exercices pratiques commencent donc par
une prise de connaissances des outils
avant de passer à la maintenance
les lycéens sont évalués sur leur
connaissance mais également sur leur
coopération et leur capacité à utiliser
et entretenir leur espace de travail
[Musique]
ça goûte plus je peux enlever le bac à
quoi va servir le circuit de
refroidissement sur notre moteur
à réguler la température de notre moteur
ouais tout à fait parce que admettons
s'il y avait pas eu ce liquide de
refroidissement dedans qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'on risque de d'avoir comme
quoi par la suite
ça veut dire que le piston ne remonte
plus
et comme dans la vie professionnelle
chaque maintenance se termine par le
rangement le nettoyage et l'entretien de
l'atelier
[Musique]
les élèves poursuivent ensuite leur
journée autour de cours théoriques
indispensables pour consolider leur
connaissance technique
présente 15 section repos
aujourd'hui nous allons faire du sweet
work ça ça va être le premier solide
qu'on va créer
donc là en ce moment on est en cours de
construction mécanique donc le but du
course de leur donner une approchant
pour santé théorique toutes les éléments
de la mécanique ce soit quittage
rotation les filetages les pieds les
ensembles mécaniques lourds et là
aujourd'hui on utilise le logiciel
Sketchup pour qu'il fasse eux-mêmes les
pièces qui vont démonter en fait c'est
pour qu'ils comprennent pourquoi on fait
ça dans ce monde on est sur une queue
d'aronde c'est une glissière classique
en mécanique pour qu'il comprenne
comment les fabriquer pourquoi elle est
comme ça les savoirs comment elle a
fonctionné
c'est des approches standards pour faire
des dessinateurs c'est pour qu'il
comprenne si on veut faire l'atelier
plus tard
on est très loin de sa famille pour
certains ben on a un avenir qui est
quand même sûr et certain on va dire on
a on a une paye on est en fait on est
dans le monde actif puis le côté
militaire c'est pas du tout comme le
civil se réveiller le matin
être au garde-à-vous c'est complètement
différent du monde civil alors
l'apprentissage c'est on est arrivé en
fin août le 25 août et on a eu deux
semaines pour apprendre à marcher ou pas
à être garde à vous faire le repos
réglementaire et après ces deux semaines
on a commencé les cours mais pour
apprendre tout ce qui est essentiel à la
vie d'un moniteur on va dire
rotation des poignets toujours en
courant
toucher le grillage chaque seconde
dépêchez-vous ça
on est 5 secondes avant claquage au sort
tout le monde alors là c'est parti on
fait refaire on fait là aussi il fait ce
soir voilà on rentre
sur le dos allez on rentre sur le dos
allez allez
alors sportivement le début était
compliqué on va dire qu'on était
beaucoup être arrivé et avoir un niveau
de sport par exemple moi en cours où
j'étais vraiment
[Musique]
pas très forte on va dire mais à force
de s'entraîner et tout ça franchement
on s'améliore de jour en jour et même si
on était on n'arrivait pas à faire une
pompe maintenant on les fait tranquille
après
tout c'est vraiment de s'entraîner si tu
as aucune motivation tu n'y arriveras
pas tout simplement
ouais ok
idéal dans la suite parcours déjà après
les deux ans avant mon bac et partir à
Saint-Maixent à l'école des
eaux-officiers
après aller dans un régiment qui me
plaît et m'épanouir là-bas et monter en
grade le plus rapidement possible et
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
je pense
à 18h et après un après-midi de sport
c'est le moment de se remettre au
travail ce temps d'étude est réservé aux
devoirs et aux révisions la vie en
internat ne sonne pas la fin des devoirs
à la maison le programme scolaire est
identique à celui d'un lycée classique
il doit être assimilé par les élèves
avant la fin de l'année afin d'être prêt
pour les épreuves du bac
plein de section de jour
les devoirs terminés place à un moment
de détente les adolescents ont laissé
leur stylo pour distiller de jeux vidéo
le temps de se retrouver un peu hors des
cours
[Musique]
l'extinction des feux se fait à 22h30
pour une bonne nuit de sommeil
[Musique]
en direction de la place d'Armes avant
départ en chantant en avant marche
[Musique]
tous les jours après les tâches du matin
l'ensemble des élèves et des encadrants
se retrouvent sur la place d'armes pour
écouter l'ordre du jour donnée par le
capitaine Mathieu commandant d'unité
[Musique]
je compte sur vous pour vous soyez
respectueux attentif et curieux et que
vous ayez les informations que vous
cherchez les encadrants militaires donc
ce sont le commandant d'unité les chefs
de section qui à la fois en cas de les
élèves dans les internats au quotidien
en fait pour gérer bien le réveil la
mise en place de la journée
la fin de la fin de soirée la fin de
journée et également assurer la
formation militaire puisque nos élèves
font de la formation militaire et
l'encadrement forme nos élèves à être
des soldats pour transmettre le savoir
être le savoir-faire militaire nous
procédons de la façon suivante en fait à
la fois nous les encadrons de façon
vraiment purement militaire avec un
rapport à l'élève qui correspond presque
à celui d'un rapport entre un cadre
militaire et un soldat adulte mais
également en ayant dans notre dans notre
approche de l'élève une certaine
bienveillance une certaine
adapté à leur jeune âge pour qu'ils
puissent bien comprendre les les
messages pédagogiques les objectifs que
l'on leur fixe
[Musique]
ça va bien se passer c'est bon pour tout
le monde
cet apprentissage il est très bénéfique
puisque ça leur permet de leur donner
des cadres des repères en fait ce qu'ils
viennent chercher généralement ici c'est
d'avoir les gens qui les structurent qui
leur donnent des ordres qui leur donnent
des cadres pour pouvoir avancer dans
leurs projets professionnels la
difficulté des élèves c'est qu'on leur
demande d'adopter une attitude plus
adulte que l'orage le demande ça veut
dire que nos élèves ont 16 ans mais on
les considère déjà un petit peu comme
des adultes de 18 19 20 ans et ça pour
eux c'est un vrai c'est un vrai défi de
pouvoir en fait répondre aux attentes
d'un encadrement adultes c'est à dire
qu'il faut réussir à trouver et leviers
pour que les élèves à la fois
travaillent s'investissent dans leur
dans leurs activités mais en même temps
tiennent en fait tiennent le coup et
arrive surtout à créer une identité
collective c'est à dire qu'il ne
subissent pas la formation militaire qui
est difficile c'est ça vraiment notre
défi c'est de créer cette dynamique
collective
[Musique]
ce matin nous retrouvons les élèves
suivant un bac pro maintenance
aéronautique pour leur premier cours de
réparation sur un hélicoptère Puma
aujourd'hui donc première séance alors
attention première séance ça peut vous
avez pas faire grand-chose je vais faire
je vais vous montrer et vous allez voir
donc profitez-en de cette séance là
parce que ça sera la seule après vous
serez autonome donc la mise en situation
je vous le dis donc le puma sa 330 c'est
toujours le même formalisme numéro xxx
reviens d'un vol d'entraînement opposer
le pilote inscrit sur la forme 11 pas de
réception vhfun et boîte de commande
vhs2 inox ok donc vous savez tout ce que
c'est une VHS une et la boîte de gants
va lâcher une
comme pour la section véhicule routiers
les lycéens sont directement instruits
sur du matériel professionnel ils font
face à de vrais problèmes techniques et
apprennent à les réparer dans des
conditions d'atelier
l'interrupteur batterie est sur OFF ok
donc vous me dites interrupteurs
donc si c'est bien fait
et là il est bien serti on n'a pas
emporté tout le lot donc je te laisse je
l'enlève je voulais faire après on peut
faire avec le radar métaux normalement
c'est comme ça on peut magouiller comme
on veut pour le sortir ok pas de souci
le but est de fournir aux unités des
sous-officiers en maintenance autonomes
ayant une connaissance du matériel
militaire dès leur sortie d'école
[Musique]
les diapos vous pouvez les sentir
et les mettre à côté pour présenter la
chaîne d'énergie chaîne d'information
[Musique]
c'est une table qui fait tourner notre
objet et éclater de scan si jamais que
il y a des capteurs dedans et ça envoie
plein de fichiers tout ça et ça scanne
je reçois tous sur mon ordinateur et
avec mon ordinateur je peux me
transférer les fichiers et je reçois mes
documents ça le but c'est après d'avoir
un objet un modèle 3D de ce qu'on est
par exemple des pièces autres que ce
qu'on a déjà imprimé quand ça peut avoir
des modèles 3D pour les reproduire
le MPT propose enfin de suivre un bac
STI2D il forme les futurs sous-officiers
dans l'emploi des systèmes de
distribution et de production d'énergie
électrique ainsi que des experts du
numérique et des réseaux de
télécommunications cette spécialité est
primordiale pour l'armée de terre par
conséquent l'investissement autour du
matériel est important dès leur première
année les élèves étudient et conçoivent
différents systèmes technologiques de
drones capteurs ou même des robots
[Musique]
on est en train on a bien de finir
d'ailleurs de monter le robot ça nous
permet déjà de voir
comment bien monter avec les différents
servomoteurs et du coup qui sont reliés
au moteur principal donc ça nous permet
de voir un peu les branchements et le
fonctionnement d'un robot et ça nous
permet aussi de pouvoir le programmer
comme on veut et après dans le manuel on
peut même faire des véhicules avec autre
chose c'est innovant par rapport
aux autres écoles parce que dans les
autres on n'a pas forcément ce genre de
matériel et pas dans ce genre
d'environnement du coup ça nous permet
de bien travailler
à fond est correctement
la filière c'est science technologique
ingénierie et développement durable
c'est vraiment de la technologie avec de
la physique et des maths on manipule
beaucoup donc on est sur des TP on
cherche vraiment à savoir comment est-ce
qu'un système fonctionne au sein de la
filière STI2D on va être divisé en deux
parties donc il y aura une partie
énergie donc ce sera tout ce qui est
installation de par exemple les énergies
solaires de panneaux ou de système pour
installer de l'eau par exemple et après
il y a la deuxième partie ce sera
système information numérique donc là ce
sera plus sur déployer la transmission
donc tu es tout ce qui est système radio
antenne et tout ça ici
hélicoïdale j'ai choisi le MPT car au
sein de cette formation je vais pouvoir
suivre mon parcours scolaire ainsi que
mon parcours militaire c'est une chance
de pouvoir le commencer à 16 ans donc on
est tout de suite dans le concret du
militaire
on commence avec des activités le
week-end mais en parallèle ensuite
formation d'un bac technologique
et donc ce bac il est important pour
l'armée qui de plus en plus innovante et
qui va être confronté de plus en plus à
la technologie
repos
combien vous êtes là l'école fonctionne
sur un juste équilibre entre encadrement
militaire et professeur
issus de l'éducation nationale
l'ambition de l'EMPT aide accompagner
les lycéens vers un taux de 100% de
réussite au Baccalauréat
accrochez-vous on fera en sorte que vous
réussissiez moi ça m'est important ici
que chacun réussisse
les cours sont prodigués par un
organisme de formation qui s'appelle le
GRETA et donc au sein de ce de cette
organisme 41 personnes des personnels
contractuels et vacataires dans la
première phase de développement de
l'école donc vous allez
sans importance
OK et après
et on va commencer
par le pensez-vous parce que il va
falloir éviter certains écueils
une fois qu'ils sont L'Oréal donc
titulaire du baccalauréat il devienne
evso ils deviennent engagés volontaire
sous-officiers dans l'armée de terre
puis ils partent en école de
spécialisation pour vraiment approfondir
leur métier au sein des armées pour les
élèves titulaires du baccalauréat
professionnel aéronautique ils ont une
mention complémentaire une année
supplémentaire ici qui équivaut à cette
école de spécialisation et il complète
leur formation militaire de base à
Saint-Maixent par la suite
à 16 ans la route est encore longue pour
les apprentis militaires après ces
années de spécialisation les jeunes
sous-officiers seront enfin prêts à
intégrer les unités de l'armée de terre
pour commencer leur carrière
donc le parcours idéal pour moi après en
jugement ça serait de pouvoir
intégrer les régiments les Forces
Spéciales bien sûr mais pour ça ça va je
suis pas très difficile tant que j'ai un
poste d'engagement de la latte ce sera
très bien pour moi c'est vraiment une
excellent aggraver à vie dans nos
mémoire pour tous les élèves de la MPT
honnêtement c'est vraiment l'une des
meilleures expériences qui peut exister
je le conseille très fortement le MPT
pour tous les jeunes qui veulent
commencer en tant que sous-officier et
c'est vraiment incroyable le MPT
représente un enjeu majeur au sein de
l'armée de terre en termes de
recrutement de fidélisation puisque en
fait à terme nous avons pour ambition de
fournir 50% des sous-officiers
techniciens de l'armée de terre de
recrutement direct ce que l'on peut
souhaiter pour nos futurs élèves c'est
qu'ils soient des sous-officiers
exemplaires dans l'émission qui vont
leur te donner aussi bien en tant que
soldat qu'on ait des soldats qui sachent
encadrés qui sachent assurer l'émission
opérationnelles qu'il leur seront donnés
mais également qu'il soit des
techniciens exemplaires professionnels
qu'il soit capable de réparer des
véhicules des matériels des matériels à
la technique des fois complexes et donc
c'est bien ça que je souhaite le MPT
[Musique]